si tu savais voilà qu'il dit tu as là si
tu savais hamon non j'aurais voulu avoir
au moins aussi joué c'était une femme
unique la mienne aussi était unique
elle avait une pour vous donner les
dessins ou d'année un homme
rien qu'en voyant ses yeux on sentait
qu'elle avait de jolies jambes
rien qu'en voyant ses jambes on sentait
qu'elle avait trop aux yeux et son
sourire angélique diabolique
aujourd'hui en main oui quand elle
sortait du bain c'était la vénus de milo
avec tes bras était la victoire de
samothrace sans les aides mais avec sa
tête
franchement honnêtement il y en avait
pas deux comme elle je l'avais rencontré
en novembre maintien sécurié moi aussi
par une soirée sans joie mais c'était le
matin est compliqué
l'important pour moi tout à coup ce fut
avril normand ce fut carrément juillet
mais il faut dire j'aime la chaleur de
qu'elle m'est apparu j'ai fait ah ah
c'est curieux moi j'ai fait ou un non
mais c'est elle qui a fait vos à moi
c'était le cas faire une heure après
l'été dans mes bras et moi dans les
cieux on s'est embrassés
longtemps très longtemps à en perdre le
souffle à en perdre la tête en oublie le
temps en billets tout tout
sauf tout de même de prendre rendez-vous
pour le lendemain bern ots tendu à midi
à nouveau moi minuit je suis un
crocheteurs à et alors là alors fait
merveille extraordinaire éblouissant
l'étourdissant enivrant exalté
sensationnel exceptionnel en un mot veux
tu que je te dise inqualifiable
franchement honnêtement il n'y en avait
pas de cannelle et puis je les revues
tous les jours moi tout les lui
elle me disait que j'étais son soleil
mois son étoile
forcément la nuit oui ça se comprend
elle avait toutes les qualités l'eau
toutes les perfections elle me disait
que j'étais le premier qu'elle a mais à
ce point moi je serais le dernier
qu'elle et moi est ainsi était aussi
doué pour la cuisine que pour l'amour
c'est pas près d'oublier nuti souper aux
chandelles dont la grande cheminée ou
crépus tel feu de bois
mais moi nos déjeuners d'amour près de
sa fenêtre fleurie comme celle de mimi
pinson
j'aimais autant ses mains de fée que
que sa tête de vous et moi sa cuisse de
9 que ses pieds panne et non franchement
honnêtement y en avait pas deux comme
elle
et puis un jour brusquement la disparue
mais il amène aussi a disparu
brusquement sans me donner la moindre
explication dont moi non plus ils sont
laissés l'adresse je passe souvent
devant son appartement au mois au 6 rue
des deux ponts thèse est curieux elle
habitait rue des deux-ponts même bien
mais aussi aux deux au 2 rue des
deux-ponts au deuxième porte unique
unique
ben mon vieux tu vois en voiture on
avait raison
il y en avait vraiment par deux comme
elle santé